ونستضيف من نابلس الان مديره مستشفى
رفيديا في نابلس الدكتور قاسم دغلس دكتور
قاسم اهلا بك تم نقل الجثامين والمصابين
الى مستشفى رفيديا ما الذي لديكم من
معلومات حول وضع المصابين اولا
والجثامين التي وصلتكم ايضا
من ثلاث شهداء
واضح انه كان هناك اصابات
تشوه وعدم
للجزائر يعني دستين الجزء الاول والراسم
مش موجود للاسف
الجزء الثالثه اصابه بالراس مع تشويه عده
اللصقات
كذلك وصلت لبعض الاصابات سنه الاصابات
بوضع المتوسط
ماذا عن هويتهم دكتور
قاسم
المزيد كلما جرى يعني تسلمتم في المستشفى
جثث
المغتالين الثلاثه الفلسطينيين الثلاثه
وتحدثت عن تشوه تعرضت له جثتان من الجثث
الثلاثه واصابه بالراس بالنسبه للجثه
الثالثه ما الذي اخبرتم به من قبل من
احضروا هذه الجتامين بخصوص ما جرى
ليس هناك شيء
واضح تم التعرف على
يعني بشكل رسمي
والجثه الثالث يتم التعرف عليها يعني
ترجمه التعرف على هويتهم
نعم
قاموا
حسب الدكتور منهم الشهداء الثلاثاء
القطماني
ومعاذ المصري او المصري وحسن قطن
يعني مش مؤكد
اذا حسن قسماني ومعاذ المصري هذا ما سمعته
صحيح للاسماء معاذ المصري وحسن
طيب في انتظار ان نحصل على دقه اكثر بخصوص
هويه الشهداء الثلاثه هل وصل مصابون
طيب وكيف وضعهم الان
طيب ماذا عن ما تحدث عنه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني من صعوبه
الوصول الى موقع حدوث هذه العمليه
للوصول الى المصابين والشهداء جرى الحديث
عن منع الجيش الاسرائيلي لطواقم الهلال
الاحمر من الوصول اليهم تفاصيل اخرى عما
جرى
نعم هذا صحيح يعني كما هو في العاده يعني
في احداث زي هيك يعني هناك صعوبه او حتى
كامل للتواصل بين الوصول الى مكان الحدث
ومكان الاصابات
بدات توصل الى المستشفى بعد انسحاب
الان لديكم فقط للتاكيد دكتور لديكم في
مستشفى رفيديا جثامين ثلاثه شهداء
بالاضافه الى ثلاث اصابات ثلاث اصابات
اذا الان وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه تتحدث
رسميا عن ثلاث ثلاثه شهداء في هذه العمليه
والدكتور قاسم دغلس مدير مستشفى رفيديا
ذكر لنا اسمين من
الثلاثه الذين استشهدوا في هذه العمليه
التي قامت بها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
في البلده القديمه في نابلس دكتور الان
وانتم في المستشفى كيف تقيمون ربما ما جرى
في هذه العمليه الى اي درجه كان الاستهداف
مباشر بالنظر الى اصابات
ان كان المصابين او الجثامين الثلاثه
يعني بالنظر
الذي استخدم
ته قذائف على الاغلب يعني التشويها وهذا
وجود
بعض راس في بعض الجثث يعني واضح انه نوع
الذخيره يعني
اذا هي قذائف استخدمت بالنظر
بالنظر ايضا الى
التشوه الذي اصاب الجثامين الثلاثه ذكرت
لنا دكتور بان
جثتين
كانت
بدون راس هذا صحيح والجثه الثالثه كانت
الاصابه بالغه ايضا في الراس
شكرا لك